warum spiele ich sowas lese meine lieben
freund und herzlich willkommen hier zu
einem spiel was einer und genau heißt da
geht es darum dass man also man kann
halt einfach wenn man dann um
ich habe keine ahnung um was es geht ein
kirche klickt man einfach auf player
friedrich cambridge mainstream kino ist
heinz helwig
[Musik]
david mckee
okay er sagt er ist kein mann er sagt er
hat keine arme und er sagt er ist kein
krieg ist wichtig nächstmöglichen
aufwärmen resolution ist dass wenn es
schwierig ist so einfach kann man etwas
von peter romberg alter that makes the
post defeated minister klar
darum spiele ich so wahlleiter ort aus
dem man diese absichtlich dumm recht
referatsleiter hatte
ich weiß ja nicht aber ich glaube ich
mache irgendwas falsch in diesem spiel
oder ich kann den ganzen schild da
einfach hinwerfen
ich stehe als ob ich jetzt hier einfach
alles durchsuchen musste niemand zuhause
klingel ist der live auf der party dance
show
da hast du n a
denn zwar schön ab freunde jetzt und
snacks mischen und kehren wir das mal
einen joint surround sound ich wünsche
und
ich versteh spiel nicht wir spielen
irgendwas anderes jetzt noch dazu power
zucker zucker kohlenhydrate zucker
kommen kommen sogar du musst nur da ein
wenig da rein in das und dann haben wir
eventuell gleich 100 drin wenn das ganze
dann noch weiter und jetzt haben wir
gleich und jeden moment und da haben wir
zeit haben wir 100 und was machen wir
jetzt und jetzt geht es weiter oder oder
wie auch da oben kommt der zucker raus
ja dann haben wir doch hier auf jeden
fall kann ich ja schon mal abwarten bis
sich einfach die 100 drin haben und dann
haben wir es auch sofort fällig dann wir
das jetzt mal über zwei ebenen dafür ist
das auf jeden fall auch schon wieder ein
spiel wo ich sagen muss er sich richtig
froh bin dass ich das auf jeden fall
noch in die kol ran genommen weil ich
finde solche spiele sollte einfach
gewürdigt werden so ein spiel das du
super programmieren einfach die stories
so und unfall unschlagbar es gibt nichts
was was irgendwas an dieser story
aussetzen könnte weil es einfach so
unfassbar was ich habe verkackt alter ja
mit dem roten da habe ich gleich alles
acht das muss auch einmal hier
durchlaufen sogar ich vollidiot ja gut
dann manchmal im reset dann lassen wir
das einmal hier durchlaufen den ganzen
zucker so dann fließt es nicht heute ich
mache jetzt auch mal hier sondern
doppelt ding und dann trennt er sich
nämlich egal ich mache etwas was ganz
ganz krasses hier schaut euch das mal an
also wenn das nicht stark ist kann der
zucker trennt sich da muss ich jetzt
hier nur hier unten so ein bisschen wie
dumm ich hätte ihn auch hier oben doch
schaut mal ganz easy going der rote
schon leer und der also ist schon voll
mit zucker und der der weiß jetzt auch
dass ich noch eben schnell ein level und
der was ist mit diesem video und es tut
mir leid dass ich dieses video heute
gemacht habe er das tut mir richtig leid
ich warte aber erstmal bisher hier oben
fällig ist dann nämlich genau jetzt
da kann ich nämlich dass wir schon mal
wieder wegpacken erwarte ich bisher hier
unten fällig ist und dann mache ich hier
nämlich so was gleich sagt perfekt das
muss jetzt nur noch irgend wieder
runterkommen alles so nice freunde wir
haben das level auch geschafft ist tut
mir ehrlich gesagt richtig leid dass ich
dieses video gemacht habe ich hatte zwei
möglichkeiten entweder ich mache ein
video wo ich einfach wenn ich in hamburg
bin oder so dann irgendwie bei der fifa
dings war ich vor zwei das habe ich hier
schon wieder am vorproduzieren und
entweder habe ich mir gedacht ich mach
dann spontan mail live video gaming und
ich finde zu meinem kanal passt besser
gaming deswegen auch immer dass das
kommen das kann ich doch eben schnell
machen das dann noch mal das auch noch
im keller nebenbei während ich habe dann
habe ich mir gedacht ich spiele einfach
dieses spiel und ich dachte man könnte
dann mehr machen ich sagte der ver sowie
bei diesem bahnhof brutales spiel dass
es da so ein paar möglichkeiten gibt bei
diesem weg your boots oder so hieß das
ja deswegen das war ein bisschen traurig
dass man da nicht so viel machen konnte
aber naja aber ich kann ja so disco
machen bub fiel runter hoch eigentlich
für das noch nicht jedenfalls habe ich
dann gedacht ich mache dann einfach
diese beiden spiele mir leid war ein
bisschen komisch wenns euch vielleicht
hatte ich nur eine bewertung freuen wir
sehen uns morgen wieder hoffentlich wenn
ich schaffe dort videos machen